[Music]
naturally I'm overwhelmed with gratitude
and warmth with the sense of pleasure
that was expressed in the years that
I've worked or done something with many
of the people who here and many of you I
especially grateful for the last 20
seconds which I recognized it also not
only very warm but also free from
hyperbole which was not true of all the
others I wish I had done some of those
fine things that people said I did but
anyway I might have tried but I don't
know they put a very golden glow on the
past
hints and ventures and efforts which as
everyone knows are never quite what the
reflective theorist says about them
later on I would make one very early
comment quick comment and that is at
fist is very poor at dates for example I
myself can't get over the feeling the
20th century began in physics the 20th
century in physics began on the first of
January 1896
well it's only four years off to be sure
but that is something but that is a date
of course which Lincoln's famous paper
discussing the x-rays it was printed
circulated through the world and began a
tremendous impetus which we still feel
from the turn of the century events the
radioactivity electron and Renkin rays
so the physicists missed that by four
years it's just not bad for all century
and I must say the organizers in some
regular 70th birthday on this date are
again taking a certain Liberty but
debating how to calculate they're only
ten percent to offer only one and a half
percent off and either of those results
is probably good enough in our trade but
something else for the benefit people
who were present last night and who took
part in our splendid dinner will exclude
I think many people come this morning to
hear these delightful talks which as
professor Lowe said to me don't steal
his idea represent kind of two poles of
excellence in our in our public
communication services a technical
brilliant clear and powerful talk and a
wide-ranging commentary of the greatest
importance to every audit or from Carl
on the one hand from Hanson the
remarkable demonstration what the
community does include but people who
are there last night will have taken
part and also witnessed a very generous
gift which people gave their superb
high-frequency receiver and transmitter
box enormous technical the latest thing
the state-of-the-art quite a marvel and
I wanted to justify them a little bit by
saying that I really am a kind of a
saturated with that strange attitude
towards radio which is characteristic of
I'll say more about it in the moment of
many other technologies in our present
world they attract people who have no
particular professional concern with
them because of the remarkable
experiences they offer and challenges
for me it goes back very far and perhaps
this anecdotal materials worthwhile so I
think that's that's appropriate such an
occasion my father who was a most active
alert intelligent man with very little
no technical training or interests and
not very much formal education the knew
his way around the world extremely well
and could calculate wonderfully mostly
the flow of the cards bought me for my
fifth birthday a remarkable device then
on sale for only had been on sale for
two weeks just two weeks in one of the
big department stores in downtown
Pittsburgh where I was growing up Josef
horn and company who sold in those two
weeks something like three
and crystal sets which we call areola
jr. there may be the Westinghouse
Electric manufacturing company and they
were intended to attract an audience to
the first broadcast station anywhere in
that part of the world of course a lot
of disputes who was first but KDKA
Pittsburgh was widely held to be the
first commercial broadcasting station in
the United States perhaps is not even
true but it's a worthwhile tradition
they brought they broadcast from the
Westinghouse plant and we lived about
three or four miles from that place and
place called Wilkinsburg PA and they
were in East Pittsburg my father knew
I'd be interested in such a thing
and sure enough for my fifth birthday I
got this remarkable affair with this
little crank like dial it's two coils
which mutual inductance was variable to
tune it and it's early solid-state
device called a crystal of Galena and a
hard wire which you touched against it
which made it possible to hear the
election returns of the Harding election
is not something very exciting to me but
but but quite a lot of other things as
well and I became glued to that and
quite a radio enthusiast from the age of
five and maybe that's responsible for
whatever else happened to me I don't
know we know that Banting tree bending
twigs inclines trees it was certainly a
severe bend to my particular twig I
remember about two years later I
organized the neighborhood kids to build
in the wastelands of high grasses and
discarded tires behind our house we
built a hidden seated nest in the woods
which many kids do at that age and we
fitted it up with powerful radio
receiver and transmitter according to my
own design the chief ingredient of which
was a broken fever from a clinical
thermometer which had a wonderful
calibration and you felt that was really
a fine device it was quite nice too I
can't say that it worked but it
it looked quite impressive and I did
become of course a devoted radio amateur
from about the age of nine and was radio
amateur for many many years until I
became a graduate student and I had to
work too hard and gave it up I hope to
go back to that if I ever can get out of
making television programs and working
too hard doing that you'll see in any
case we turned the set on last night it
has marvelous 40 or 50 push buttons and
levers and so on even to read the manual
would take two hours so we just played
around I did coax a few signals out of
it and when we left then I left this
morning I had already heard you know
quite a lot of the usual powerful
broadcast station you know how that
works it works fine it's a wonderful
device it has full of severe or
phase-locked loops which give it a
powerful way to pick out frequencies and
I tried it on WWV the father of time and
Fort Collins Colorado the official
station I noticed with considerable
admiration for the designers that the
frequency recorded in this 10 megacycles
area was 10 100 0.0 when I dead beat
so they have their act together between
Fort Collins and the firm so I do thank
you all took part of that and those who
just willing to listen to it it was an
exciting wonderful gift for somebody who
has quite a lot of things and doesn't
need much more but this was splendid
now I want to talk a little while and I
think my my tasks I'm gonna make a
rather brief talk but I want to talk for
a little while about community is that
surely is what we were celebrating and
discussing here a community of shared
tasks mutual interests of widespread
commonly felt concerns of experiences
positive and negative attractive and
repulsive which we've all come to in the
many bilateral and many body exchanges
which occur in a professional group like
ours I'm speaking the physics community
and especially that sub branch of it
mostly people here who have drifted a
little bit from the purest physics into
astronomy including of course from the
beginning and Spader who couldn't stay
away from the stars once nuclear physics
couldn't be powerful there and is still
dealing with the same old star after all
these years
I had a hard time thinking what how to
order this thing and I thought there was
a wonderful cosmic order which I would
use it is the fact that we share world
lines and though we know our times are
distinct because our motions are not
zero they are breathe small and
therefore I think we all say there is a
public time which we on earth and even
people in orbit or in the solar system
share too high accuracy good enough for
all everyday purposes and we can deal
with that so I try to order things a
little bit in in that order so to make
you feel something of the experiences
that I want to tell about I'm going to
try to stay away for the most part from
discussing giving you wonderful things
to say about some of the people who are
here but if you send a self-addressed
stamped envelope maybe I could fill
those in it is true that a community is
built not only by the things that I've
talked about are the real things that
are behind it the day by day and year by
year reading and talking and arguing and
exchanging letters and fighting and
agreeing and so on contesting for this
and that and agreeing for this and that
but also by tradition and record that is
to say by things that are expressed and
made public this is a necessary part of
it
publication the most formal and bar
conversations the least formal both of
great importance as everyone knows so I
want to say a few of those things mostly
by people you won't know of but they
reflect if not if you don't know about
them
you at least see me saying them and that
provides a kind of relevance to the
situation and I first want to say that I
never can face such a account as we had
this last day or two as I had even ten
years ago a similar related sort of
thing
without thinking of the first time I
listened to a talk by the distinguished
and wonderful American physicist
astronomer Henry Norris Russell from a
different generation but also a man who
had a great to do with with the magazine
which I worked so happily for many years
and a man whose name is carved firmly
into the physics of atomic spectroscopy
let alone the Stars and their nature
which was his real study the first time
I saw Henry Norris Russell I was a
rather callow sophomore he was present
at a meeting this Astronomical Society
in Pittsburgh which at a Christmas time
when the triple-a asked the American
Association of dance Messiah has met
there and many scientific organizations
met in their ambience in their halo more
than do now from the physical sciences
though the biological sciences and are
strongly still represented and I
remember thinking to myself that which
had already gathered this view from
literature so his pops not an original
idea I imputed something to the world
that astronomers must be people great
longevity here was this vigorous man
saying very nice things a little bit of
which I could understand not much but
clearly a man full possession of all his
powers and he was formatively old I
thought of geological age he was
according by researchers about 61
so again the relativity of perception is
made very clear in order to add a to
steal a certain distinction from the
past I should now like I was I was
reminded of my two encounters which the
with the most famous name in the 20th
century physics the name of their
wonderful Albert Einstein that man I
mentioned it because it's the very same
occasion in the Christmas season 3334
yes there was a sophomore that Einstein
came to Pittsburgh exactly as Russell
did for the same general purpose to
attend the triple a us meeting that was
a time when Einstein had not yet
realized fully that dreadful social
malady which affected him in America
name if he walked down the street to buy
a newspaper he would acquire a an
accompaniment of 300 people if you were
not careful except in Mercer Street and
Princeton and a little bit in the
neighborhood this made his life as he
said repeatedly written difficult
because he couldn't do the normal thing
couldn't go to the theater he couldn't
go to the beach without making it kind
of a strange situation so he hadn't
learned that Jeff he learned it in
Pittsburgh he announced the top to the
section the Physical Society which was
meeting there quite a straightforward
Pleasant elementary pedagogical talk
deriving the Lorentz transformations
from momentum conservation by a new
method which he had just thought and I
don't remember the details but it's
published and was quite useful for
people who were taught about relativity
and he gave this little talk to a
meeting expected of 150 people or so the
registrants of the of the society well
of course you know what happened the
place couldn't hold it and so the huge
demands for getting in and so the
triple-s hired the largest theatre
available at that hour and then began to
give out tickets because they couldn't
control the crowds and of course all of
us physics students who lived and worked
at the Carnegie Tech campus which was
1500 feet from the Kentucky theater
where this was held couldn't stand the
fact that we had no chance
getting in anymore because we had no
right to those tickets they were given
out you know to all sorts of dignitaries
and so the whole place was gonna be feel
with 2,000 people 25 of whom we were
interested in the topic and the rest
we're interested in saying they had seen
professor Einstein which is not an
unworthy thing I'm not trying to write
it down but it obviously it had its
price its price on professor Einstein
himself and a little bit of its price in
the currency of science but the students
undergraduate says this university knows
very well are not easily constrained by
the architects and the formal rules and
the police and all those things I want
to do something and so the place was a
theater and the Carnegie Tech has this
drama school and Drama School is full of
people who know a lot about theaters and
quite a few who had rehearsed in this
very theater so it didn't take much
looking around to find so we said ok
we'll get you in don't worry we'll all
go there together and of course I ended
up well this place is too small
but in a place way up there and by
looking at my angle of view was very
small and it contained the rear of the
stage and so I could get from time I
could get a very good view of the edge
of the blackboard but not the blackboard
and an occasional view of the top of
Albert Einstein at his hand
and we couldn't hear a word and we were
in some peril of falling out of the flag
on to the snake which we avoided but
anyhow that was my first encounter with
this great man and great physicist and
it's only rather amusing to talk about
it but I did want to add another story
another authentic genuine eyewitness
account of Einstein's sense of humor and
repartee and understanding which I'll
make very brief because it's not my job
to do that there are there only a few
people now who are witnesses and I
understand that one of the best is is
here Fester Peter Bergmann and I said I
would just allude to that so if you
wanna know the real goods ask him but if
you want to hear a story I'm good enough
for that and I was introduced by a
mutual friend who lived on Mercer Street
to Professor Einstein very late in
Einstein's life only a couple of years
before his death and it was a very
pleasant Sunday afternoon I went over
just as any guest would go to Princeton
household on Sunday afternoon the
chattered nanti all that and we talked
about the political situation in 1953 or
so is not very good and we had mutual
understanding on that but I don't want
to say all that about the conversation
but I don't mention one remark Einstein
and you asked me what I was doing it was
that a young professor doing a cosmic
race or other things and he said I
realize said Einsteins that there are
two great enigmas in the world which I
myself have not give any time to study
but I think they're very important and
they will contain in them something of
great value one of them he said is the
origin of the Earth's magnetic field and
the second he said is the origin of the
cosmic rays we don't understand these
two things and I'm sure that there is a
deep piece of physics in in the solution
to these two problems well this was a
gift I must say because I knew something
about those problems that we didn't know
the answer is not sure I know yet but I
do something about those problems so I
said
as diplomatically as I could manage well
professor Einstein I don't think it's
fair to say that these are really big
enigmas going deep into the heart of
fundamental physics they might have been
at one time but it's not - any longer
we do have a general idea of how both of
them work we don't know where or when or
in detail but they seem both to be
related to what I will call for short I
said it a little better than hydro
magnetics that is the idea of magnetic
fields in fluid conductors which are
capable of translating bulk mechanical
energy to charge particles by this
interaction between a current which is
walked to a big massive fluid and a
single particles to respond to the
moving magnetic field and this is
probably in some way related to the
Earth's magnetic field and in some way
related acceleration of cosmic rays he
has to questioner to it I satisfy anyone
he had never heard of a vein or an I get
hydrodynamics or any of those matters as
far as I could tell unless it was just
being very polite and finally he smiled
a little bit said well he said I see in
any case Morris and you can rest assured
that in your work
Einstein is no competition
this was pretty good assurance
I can't fairly go ahead a little bit so
I said was doing a booty sequence
I jumped that I was made a slight
mistake but I'm let me go back a little
bit because my I was thinking so much of
my student days that I put the to
Einstein stories together as a student
of course I was fairly ingenuously
graduate student or I arrived I come
from Carnegie Tech a good school with
excellent interaction with the
physicists who by the way had by their
simple being there had seduced me away
from the radio engineering that I was
planning to take up when I became a
freshman I only had to go to six
lectures metrical engineering and six
lectures and physics to see that my
heart belonged with the physicists the
subject matters might have been much the
same but the attitude the community into
which I see myself working was so
different the exploratory seeking grasp
not satisfied with mere compact results
unexamined to go to the next step and so
on and there was so much more of my
style that I became for better or worse
the physicists I never did become radio
engineer thought I worked at it a little
bit in my college days when I went to
Berkeley in 1936 I began to become
interested in nuclear physics and of
course what I had was the wonderfully
clear and powerful article always known
as beta in bakker but especially Part A
the theory was confessori betas work of
the time and it was a good thick
compendious object which I didn't
understand very well which I studied in
the study the studies and kept around
and finally got to know quite a bit from
inside it and I'm dazzled and delighted
to be able to come back 50 years and
still have such a sample of
understanding about these things so
nicely given us by fester baited himself
this morning and it's a great pleasure
of course Hantz is a kind of second
teacher of mine and we we worked
together for years
book together he wrote the beginning and
I modified it very happily and I have to
regard him as a white house not always
clear sometimes little foggy out there
but definitely the direction you want to
go and there he still is I have to say
that I was specially poor at Neutron
physics I never figured out that part of
the chapter very well until I was taking
the University of Illinois a little bit
later I had my degree then sort of
electrodynamics a QED degree with three
or four papers in applications of QED to
various nuclear atomic problems very
very instructive and very pleasant and
elective a lot learn a great deal worked
with my partners dan coffey shift Cooper
and a few others and we were a very
cheerful part of that remarkable
assemblage of my fellow students who
were the students of Robert Oppenheimer
in the last of the 30s when I went to
the University of Illinois I found
myself in an office and the other man in
that office I was a very junior
instructor he was getting ready to go
away was none other than M gold Javert
and I knew he must know something about
neutrons
since essentially he discovered them and
had kept up with it quite a lot and
indeed he was indeed busily working on
Neutron diffusion problems reason didn't
quite understand which I understood
pretty soon when he went away to Chicago
where I felt there was lots of people
affected that but I was very very little
understanding about those matters but I
was understanding enough so that he this
is a repeated story all over the world
was probably worth saying it has
enduring historical meaning in the early
spring of 39 in LeConte hall room 219
with a few other graduate students we
spent a long afternoon we were always
that was Robert off a members empty
office the adjoining office we always
talked and argued about things there and
that afternoon we were led to think
about grave matters and we
constructed on the blackboard an
extremely naive but not wholly absurd a
model of a nuclear bomb this was of
course February or March I can't say
which of 1939 safely after the Frisch
Meitner articles that are sued by
fission and in the hands of people much
about neutrons but do some catch words
and some broad qualitative ideas about
what neutrons would do and how a
reaction might propagate and we had we
were not clever enough to think of
delayed neutrons on that but we
understood what fast neutrons would do
and it was good enough so that was a
kind of sign of the trouble which then
cut me up in the war and I won't say
very much more about this
it's a long discussed problem I do want
to mention though when I look at this
excellent people here yesterday did
large be sampling my whole world there
are very few people around who still go
back to the Berkeley days that I recall
there are two or three I want to mention
were absent Dale Corson who could not be
here and Robert Wilson who was lecturing
in Yugoslavia today and there about the
last of my fellow graduates to whose
location I could be named most of them
are not here
the other one is Bernard and Hannah
Peters whom I knew in Berkeley in 1938
and I think that somewhat takes the
record for longevity of association
among people I've met Alvin Weinberg
claims that he saw me at a Beethoven
quartets in this late summer of 1936 in
Berkeley but we couldn't quite verify it
he claims I was fixing the audio
equipment but I don't remember that
though it was certainly possible and it
may be that he was he's writing that
would ante dated a little bit because I
had not I didn't do that long at
Berkeley I just barely got a room before
after high week when I'm still doing
that job I also would like to describe
as part of this sort of anecdotal may
large they're just beginning here I want
to say a little bit more self-justifying
stuff in a moment more generalized way
but it's nice to have a few such items I
very clearly remember that I cannot tell
you the exact date or the exact place
but I remember it was a physical Society
meeting
in the mid-60s and it will have taken
place someplace where the spring Sun was
shining on the grassy lawns and I
suppose that was the Washington meeting
the physical society and there I was
approached by Ray Davis whom I knew very
very slightly but Ray had read something
I had written about doing neutrino
astronomy and things of this sort and he
said he told me his plan for burying the
cleaning fluid in a big tank in the
bottom of the Homestake mine and
cleverly extracting from 20 tons of the
stuff 20 atoms per month or whatever it
was he was talking about to check the
neutrino and did you think it was
worthwhile most people thought said he
that was all calculated there was no
need doing anything about it and I said
don't believe that for a moment they
don't know anything about its way to
look inside the Sun and do it and on his
behalf with many people I did what
little politicking one could in favor
the experiment must say was was
brilliantly supported the end by the
Brookhaven laboratory and by the
authorities beyond that and got us this
long rigorous series of month after
month disappointing answers that never
fitted all those clever theorists work
and he stuck to it as had said and out
of that sense of integrity will perhaps
come already has come and remarkable
study the interior the Sun that seems to
verify probably will the picture in the
Stars but also as Hansel's opened up to
us because there were more that we can
look after which we never imagined but
there's no use having a result that is
popular for the moment but does not
endure it's much better to have result
however I'm popular however frustrating
indoors because it is I think right and
that's what we try to that's what we ask
for it always get it so it's 20 years
since that happened it's a wonderful
wonderful conclusion it's very hard to
work the time after time in a deep mind
and always come back with that same
result and you try this or that
statistic and matter what you do you
still get a disappointing answer another
remark which was made by Alan Guth
yesterday I want to pick
a little bit just to mention people this
is something that has been published I
don't know this of my own I just read it
and I verified it with the author so
it's true it's the story of the enormous
intuitive perception of that thoughtful
reflective man niels bohr who having
thought about all hard problems was then
able to see when you brought him with
some new thing which of the hard
problems he thought about it was
connected with which any salt and
Casimir Hendrik Casimir writes said in
the Bohr volume of that remarkable
calculation of kazimierz on the forces
between the so-called van der Waals
forces in the limits when you throw away
all the molecular structure you get an
answer which does not depend on any of
those points it doesn't depend on the
charge of the electron or anything else
and you go to the right limit in looking
at surface surface interactions
he made that calculation rather puzzled
him there should come out such a result
but it was clear he mentioned it to Bohr
and more looked at him quizzically in
that way that he had we know something
quite important have a look he said ah
then Casimir that is due to the
fluctuations of the vacuum and that is
what we believe and I think the
fluctuations of vacuum on which one of
my three pieces my thesis was on pair up
tuitions in the vacuum I think they have
acquired now they've been sort of very
under the rug for a long time then they
were shown to be real in the great days
per set precedent too and just following
the Lamb shift where the polarization
terms were visible and the Casimir
effect and that verification
experimentally and now of course the
interpretation still ambiguous but now
giving them gravitational meaning has
led to a whole quandary which we don't
understand but which looks to be about
as important as any cosmological
theoretical subject that we know and
it's an interesting study now enough of
these points but I want I think I in I'm
entitled to some account you're entitled
perhaps to some account of why these
wayward
apparently extraneous items which dotted
these per this program I think very
pleasantly and I hope for you as well
but including the balloons or whatever
you say how come that a physicist should
have this and I believe it to be the
most natural thing in the world and
that's we're going to try to say in the
self justification why are these things
here and what relation do they have to
professional work of the physicists I
believe that in this order of importance
at least important first but a very
interesting case which we had
demonstrated magic mime and more broadly
playful science and engineering are
topics of the greatest weight and
importance in the modern world and I
think it is it is urgent upon many
people especially those who have
academic influence you don't need to
worry about it at MIT it's safe here
these extra care activities of students
span such an enormous range of playful
engineering and playful science that if
faculty does have to tell them what to
do but just get out of the way and maybe
give them though money from time to time
it's not true everywhere it is
unfortunately the least true where is
the most needed that is in the broad
public in the schools and people that
are not so available who do not have
available all the resources of our
campus but magic of course is
essentially the exploitation of a
detailed physical knowledge of systems
in such a clever way a cover
interpersonal way that you are
misdirected from trying to understand
the answer it was done for us yesterday
by two adepts theoretical physicist
astrophysicists called Kevin Brecher who
punctured balloons he tells me just like
that you just puncture it and max maven
another old friend
Furyk astrophysicists only by descent
who who also who carried on very much
more elaborate and and polished to fare
in much the same direction but this is
very interesting because both of the
this procedure depends upon a detailed
understanding step by step understanding
of a mixture of psychology and Newtonian
mechanics
the physical chemistry and the like and
that's what it is and it isn't much else
it also is a great understanding of
human perception where you look at big
moving things and don't look at small
things that stand still and a number of
other such clues that you're quite easy
to face up to if you try to analyze what
you mean by the instruments through
which you survey the world that is your
eyes ears and so on and of course nobody
can in general without long training can
penetrate the rapid-fire quick changing
goals and methods of the professional
magician or even the talented amateur
and it's very worth trying but it will
not generally succeed but understanding
that point and understanding she is very
entertaining and is deeper because it
suggests what is meant by there is
between of plausible perception and the
kind of testing perception which is our
aim in physical sciences in Natural
Science and that's really the point that
it makes mime which is a specialized
form of stage magic of stage performance
I think is especially interesting it has
always caught my fancy especially the
hands the great French master hands and
feet of the great French masters because
they require detailed understanding much
as the theoretical physicist seeks to
have of some mechanical operation in
order to simulate its perceptual
qualities without actually doing it when
mysel Marceau walks across the flat
stage telling you he's climbing seven
steps seven flights of stairs in the top
of some Paris Gerrits you can see the
motion of all the muscles you can see
him tiring you can see the tensions
change
it's compellingly convincing it's there
persuasive and he's only been able to do
that by watching carefully over and over
again one of the significant clues as
that stance is adopted in a way it's a
representation of the real physical
world through a symbolic and analogous
structure which is very much like what
physicists do and I think it's very
close to that deserves it the wide
appreciation it does have finally a much
larger topic I don't want to elaborate
on is what I call playful engineering
and science that means everything from
toy balloons to kites and the great
fence for us 30 miles across California
by the artist Christo why do I say these
things I think you should be quite clear
if we regard science technology if the
general world regards nice technology
has only the source on the one hand of a
livelihood constantly subject to change
and on the other hand of a fear of war
also subject to uncertain and terrifying
changes I don't think our activities
will prosper I think they will become as
already they have in many ways become
regarded as arcane and fearful and a
great many people stay right from at all
costs that perhaps the worst of that is
a bit over but it certainly were gone
through it and I think that one reason
for is we always present it it's always
better in the same emotional tone even
by us impact sometimes good sometimes
bad usually bad or by its achievement
and the part of people that you can't
emulate or understand those are the two
ways which it appears to us mostly and
it can't be left in that emotional
domain of simple analysis or impact
statements it's fine but it's not enough
it must be done but it is insufficient
and I think it'd be much more rounded
if the prose and the emotional tone or
the context which you encounter these
things have the participants of
enthusiastic amateurs and have the
emotional tone of play as much certainly
for the general public as enthusiasts
who certainly have that emotional tone a
great deal even when they're doing their
most serious work and the fact that we
filter that away is very bad so it was
Jerrold Zacharias in this institution
that pushed me into a wider spectrum of
education away from education centering
on the community physicists which I was
heavily engaged in gave many lectures
and many little booklets and courses and
so on and into a feeling the education
was a wider spectrum than that which of
course he was absolutely right into a
beginning first in high school then
largely influenced by Francis Friedman
into the elementary school and here and
there into the media both through my
magazine connection for so many years
and repeatedly
in the BBC and in PBS to television in
some form or another now which I'm
heavily engaged in at the present time
would be certainly the next half a year
anyhow I don't say much more about that
but I feel it's an absolutely natural
boundary of physics physics doesn't take
care of that boundary make sure that
there's free tourism across that
boundary and that the customs officials
are not too strict a lot is important a
lot is exported that's what we need for
a healthy science a lot of physicists in
every department know a good deal about
say solid-state manufacturing there or
anything of this sort and that they
don't know anything like that much about
the schools and how they work was an
early complaint of both of Zack's and
which I think I share so I very much
think that besides what I said the
playful side of the thing in the public
and amateur way the educational boundary
is another important boundary and then
of course in a somewhat different
different vein it's the most natural
thing in the world to be concerned about
armaments it has to be said that indeed
the most fearsome who were made by us
often by the people I see here in many
ways it was not the government general
groves who came to the physical society
and said appoint 12 experts to form a
committee to see if we should make an
atomic bomb it was not that way at all
and maybe that be maybe today but it
certainly wasn't that way then and the
illusion that it was that way which
affects many people is a false statement
the situation as you know is was almost
the opposite I'm not saying this to
execute or involve anybody but simply a
true statement or you have to evaluate
it as you will the physicists demanded
the darn things for reasons which they
seemed good and sufficient to them which
I still think probably weren't good the
sufficient in light of what we knew and
they finally got them but it wasn't at
the urging of the government so I think
that responsibility was boarded and
everyone and the I could say by the heat
of the that I felt in my face at the
Trinity shot at 18,000
yards I was pretty well committed to
doing something about getting the thing
put into a proper situation and our very
large international society I can't talk
about these matters in great detail and
I just allude to them in this simple way
certainly it was there and I was very
pleased that Randi forsberg talked about
her wonderfully analytic and devoted
concern for this question for many years
now and only feel sorry that Jerry
Wiesner was not present too and
reinforced that from a quite different
perspective
now finally then the other boundary
which indeed I reached I guess sort of
about the same time was the boundary
between physics and astronomy no tight
boundary at all but a very leaky one and
wonderfully crossed as somebody said by
the physicists post-war physicists as it
was begun by the pre-war ones and of
course as it goes back to the time of
Newton Galileo measured studied the
inertial forces and Galileo developed
the telescope and discovered the
satellites of the planets apart from the
natural satellite and that's a nice a
nice model and of course astronomy with
its extraordinary parametric range and
its sense of history inescapable to it
has come more and more to be an
important subject for the physicist the
physicist used to be outside of history
and not talk about origins not talk
about the origins of matter or the
origins of the universe or even the
origins the laws are now somewhat
concerned with these problems and as we
heard think that I have an answer which
I think is undoubtedly a little
premature but we have something going in
that direction I would not bet we're not
going to learn a great deal I entered
this through Professor Rossi pretty much
I was always an astronomy for a very
long time but it was the through the
cosmic rays and as one of the I guess it
was a quotation from a paper that showed
yesterday the fact that the cosmic rays
had been a wonderful particle physics
laboratory
was done for at a certain time in the
early 50s not because it was not still
an excellent particle physics laboratory
but because it just lost productivity if
you waited for six months at Echo Lake
for a hundred tracks you could hardly
compete with some character in Berkeley
or Brookhaven who was getting micro
amperes in his beam beautifully sorted
and prepared when he could press a key
on they would come it was very hard to
stay in that game a few adroit people
still do it by combing the very
high-energy tail where there are fewer
and fewer events which they study with
more and more care but clearly that's a
game not many people can engage in and
so it was here at MIT that it slowly
arose and around faster goal well it was
Cornell there slowly arose the feeling
that after all cosmic rays were not just
particles they were astronomically born
particles and we learned something about
astronomy by following them back to
where they came from and as we followed
them back we got somewhat lost from
cosmic rays and found x-rays and many
other things
meanwhile the radio people coming from a
still more engineering point of view
yesterday I had the label on which was G
on skis data from 1932 the first the
sign that the interference that he
picked up on 20 meters was varied inside
real and not in solar time that's the
expression in a nutshell and that was
the beginning of the sense that we
indeed should study radio Stony as well
as optical and of course by now the
whole gamut and we have neutrino
astronomy of some sort at least solar
astronomy in some hopes for the rest
that's what I want to say and I think
that I have lived long enough to see the
realization of something I heard which
impressed me very sensible and
philosophical and right coming from
Niels Bohr in 1937 at Berkeley when an
answer to a question Bohr says one of
his public lectures then which I heard
notes on is a very eager graduate
student that the trouble with cosmology
which was then a real subject but was
geometrical in nature consisted in
studying solutions of even equation and
not much else
was that there was it was essential to
understand the nature of matter in order
to have a
way to go deeper into cosmology and
unfortunately there was no context in
which the nature and structure of matter
was found together with cosmologically
interesting times and places and until
that context should arise said he we
will probably not understand the one or
the other and of course that context now
has arisen if we are right in the early
universe and maybe we'll find more as
time goes on that's a pressure thing
well I'm coming close to the end of all
that I want to say but I have a little
more I received many warm letters people
couldn't be here I think too many to
read you but I will receive one which
was so apt that I can't suppress it it
came from that irrepressible Giuseppi
cocconi a very original man a very
knowing in a cute one who was relatively
quiet and in his demeanor and so you
don't hear a lot about him but it's very
shortly he said that he has
unfortunately unable to come because he
finds himself in a very unusual location
exactly on this day Saturday the 27
September I would give you a few guesses
to work Akoni might be but this one is
perhaps the most interesting
I suppose the South Pole be a
possibility compete with it but no he is
in that famous and remote City the
capital of Tibet the city of Lhasa don't
ask me how or why he got there but
that's why he's not here today he said
perhaps some kind of communication will
be established by this note and I hope
he will learn by slow means with long
propagation time that indeed it was
accomplished in that sense as far as we
can do it we're here signal delay
retardation is
and can't be done as though we were in
one time scale I would like to make real
thanks to the apt to the able and
energetic and patient and thoughtful
committee and all that helpers who've
arranged this fine occasion for us all
and I imagine people would like to join
[Applause]
and I cannot allow the general comment
in the committee who are my good friends
go by without make saying just a few
words to celebrate and recognize that
the artists experimental scientists
craftsmen designer engineer caring
devoted loving and hopeful person
Phyllis
with whom I have lived
[Applause]
now let me close by fulfilling the title
of the of the talk which said remarks at
an equinox actually printed remarks of
an equinox but that's really hard to
accept I'm not an equinox
no one can call me that without smiling
but I am at an equinox in two ways
this is the equinoctial week after all
and of course the autumn comes and I
only want to point out to the physicist
who have a good sense of continuity and
a good sense of the relativity of
geometrical form that we say this is the
autumnal equinox but boy what right do
we say that it is of course as everyone
knows in Australia the vernal equinox
and I think that's the symbol that I
would like to leave that time passes but
as long as we have representation of the
young of students of concern as long as
it can keep the peace I think we need
not worry about the future that is I put
some a problem and therefore let me
close in a slightly less philosophical
note I can't avoid the feeling that we
have responsibility to act as we have a
responsibility to know I don't do
anything formal by once I do have a very
nice letter here which has been drafted
by a friend and activist friend for
speaker O'Neill here in the 8th
congressional district Massachusetts we
have a special opportunity and a special
responsibility there half a million
people in this district who all know
about speaker T P O'Neill the senior
member of the House of Representatives
and the Speaker of the House is retiring
no longer in contention he's a man whose
own growth and political perception I
think I've watched in 20 years and I've
waited for it and as you may not know
perhaps the house represents past very
narrowly yesterday their final cut at a
bill for which authorizes hundreds of
billions of dollars in government
expenditures including the good fraction
rhetoric spares not the whole bill yet
putting into it at the strong
recommendation in the House Armed
Services Committee three important arms
control statements which represent the
opinion in the house if and I think of
the population
if not of the executive branch mandating
a nuclear warhead test ban under certain
circumstances
so they define no money spent to violate
that no money spent to bring down any
satellite target in space better to
maintain the ASAP moratorium and
retaining the salt to limits no one need
to be spent to violate those limits with
nuclear weapons these are in the bill
they're passed it will now have to be a
big struggle in the next month to see
what happens to them but of a warm note
of support appreciation might be worth
well and your summary for o'the us that
are wrote quite eloquently the
Constitution gave to the house as well
as to the Senate the power of the purse
precisely to counter the power of an
adamant executive so I have this letter
and I'd be very happy if anybody wants
to join me in signing it Justin as a
colleague and friend no institutional
connection is there I'll have it all day
and will circulate whoever wants to do
it so I close with thanks then and what
I say is let the kites fly
[Applause]
don't go away please
there is still to be a presentation by
mr. Brian Moser who's the who's the
president of the MIT undergraduate
organization professor Morrison the
respect and admiration of the students
here is clear he represent very much the
MIT spirit I recall my first contact
with MIT was before I came to my team
and I was a sophomore in high school and
I remotely knew what MIT was about but
my parents called and they said Brian
there's there's somebody on TV giving a
lecture and there's some some crazy
physics professor from MIT and they
called me in and I sat with incredible
enthusiasm and became excited about MIT
in college for the first time and so you
really have an impact on students here
in that spirit I recall last night after
our meal the challenges that my
generation the scientist has and I think
did you stand there's an incredible and
perfect model for a balance of
intellectual playfulness and at the same
time a human critic to critical humanity
skepticism we all know what I'm saying
and
and we thank you for that and that'll
you will stand as a model for us as we
as we challenge the pressures on us to
become more narrow and to forget how
human we all are and on behalf of the
undergraduates and the students at MIT I
like to think thank you and wish you a
happy equinox and a happy birthday and
first we have for you a framed and also
when you see me also since we were all
about to go and have a picnic together
we have for you Alan a kite for you to
fly in case your transmitter breaks down
you can tie a few messages to the string
[Applause]
you